so it so good there's convict Lindsey
ever my name is Ellie Walker I work out
rocket on marketing work that is Nessa
great joke right 20 articles pitching
I've never been know how sometimes I my
heart is pounding right now I have not
been often come before but I'm really
looking forward to my first time it will
smell like sex s oh god aah oh no man
hoping it smells like tea 1040 haha i'm
going to take help or something pepper
can you fight be good for you it's like
not terrible tasting I think you like to
sleep cuz legs are underground tour
their pics kind of me mashonaland mom
I'm most excited for peyote documents i
use class house every day at schoo
bijendra yo male kitten they said for
sure no I think our hopefully there will
be somebody on either side of me you
know I mother nervous before vanilla
nervous but these parts where they asked
to infection there were people getting
wet but it bit the front door oops i
mean the hope is really choked it down
to baileys deficit excuse me no matter
no that's not going to happen but no i'm
not i hope it consists I was close to
station possible probably 26 million
gotta guess like
[Music]
man i gotta pass I sobbing
[Applause]
[Music]